depuis le rivage du dniepr on peut
apercevoir les six réacteurs de la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe aux
mains des russes depuis début mars
de notre côté du fleuve la ville de
nikopol est régulièrement la cible
d'attaqués ces derniers jours d'où
viennent les bombardements russes les
habitants n'ont aucun doute ils tirent
tous les jours toutes les nuits depuis
1h godard c'est là que se trouve la
centrale et du coup les forces aux
ukrainiennes ne peuvent pas répliquer
parce qu'ils risqueraient de toucher la
centrale justement la place jaune c'est
ton dont inscrits du dur dur la nuit sur
coup on dort vraiment mal
d'après energo atom l' agence qui gère
les centrales nucléaires du craignent n
les forces russes ont stocké au moins 14
unités de matériel militaire lourd près
d'un des réacteurs
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour se
barricader là dedans
ils ont placé tous leurs véhicules au
fond de la salle des turbines
des véhicules des armes et des munitions
la question est qu'est ce qu'il se
passera s'il ya un feu il sera
impossible de les teindre parce que
leurs véhicules bloquent l'accès aux
pompiers
une situation d'autant plus préoccupante
qui a régulièrement des combats à l'armé
à feu près de la centrale à nrk d'art la
semaine dernière trois militaires russes
ont perdu la vie et deux autres ont été
blessés des informations rapportées par
le maire de la ville en exil
je ne peux pas écarter l'hypothèse qu'il
s'agissait d'opérations défense du
craignent n il faut savoir qu'il ya
aussi une compétition interne parmi les
occupants pour rester dans la centrale
donc ils se battent aussi entre eux en
fait ils se servent de ça pour justifier
leur présence en disant regardez il ya
des résistants donc il faut bien qu'on
reste là pour réduire la menace
moscou accuse les forces ukrainienne de
se livrer à des activités militaires sur
la centrale qui pourrait mener je cite à
une catastrophe nucléaire pour toute
l'europe un moyen de faire porter la
responsabilité du risque sur kiev et de
justifier ainsi le renforcement de la
présence militaire russe sur place